how much effort was that you know how
how much sweat and tears and toil was it
for you to achieve this moral virtue
that is saying something really extreme
you know you didn't build a house you
didn't climb a mountain you didn't raise
a child you didn't construct a building
you said something on the internet you
know it's amazing that that gives people
cred
i am very happy to see how well you're
doing with lotus leaders at the moment
man it's really impressive the team's
massive
it's huge isn't it yeah there's like 13
people in the office now we're waiting
for the next in the office next to us is
the uh the transport police that you saw
when you came down
we're waiting for them to leave so we
can expand into their office because
they've got a huge office and we're just
going to essentially just take it over
so i'm i'm looking forward to it get
another get another set what does it
feel like going from being just some
blokey youtuber to now you know a
proper company media team research yeah
it's exciting right like because before
i could feel myself getting wearied by
right now i'm gonna have to read these
things and do this and the the you know
you have to do all the back end stuff
and it was just tiring and it you know
it sapped the motivation to do the
things you know but now we've got like
you know two people who do the video
production and then we've got other
people who are doing other things and so
i and it's lots of other you know
because we're all in the same office and
i've been very insistent we work in the
office uh you get lots of different
ideas being thrown into the sort of the
ring and it's not just me having to
think of everything myself and have to
do everything myself and so it makes it
a completely different environment and
the office is a really chill place and
everyone seems to have a good time there
as well and so
everyone's being very creative with what
they're doing it's turning into quite
the little think tank
i'm very very happy then it's it's
it's definitely a good idea i'm so i
knew it would be i had this instinct was
like yeah that would probably be a good
thing to have uh and it would be nice to
be able to bring other people in to do
stuff and i i'm glad that that was
correct a good instinct
yeah man it doesn't surprise me i went
down the atmosphere is cool i mean
you've got your own servers and [ __ ] in
there as well you're as protected as you
can get it's um
you know what you guys do is the closest
thing i think we've got in the uk to the
daily wire and that's one hell of a
[ __ ] operation
yeah i mean we're nowhere near the scale
of the daily wire but um you know we get
something like seven or eight million
views a month on our youtube channel um
you know 200 000 on the website which is
not that bad actually because obviously
seriously speaking of speaking of
youtube dramas and people that are
worried about losing their business
what's your thoughts on ethan klein's
recent spat with john peterson
i think that what we're witnessing is
the inevitable radicalization of ethan
klein because of his twitter usage uh
ethan obviously used to be a sort of
anti-social justice uh commentator he
used to mock all of this and
little by little and i think it's
because of the
natural environment of twitter having
purged so many conservatives and
suppressing
viewpoints that essentially just makes
it seem like the the only
and
most sensible and common viewpoint is
that of the far left i mean it's written
in twitter's terms of service you can't
misgender people and things like this
and there are so many the the political
environment is so skewed on the platform
that it becomes a sort of water in which
you swim and
i don't think ethan klein is the
smartest person in the world and so i
don't think he recognizes that
and i mean
take for example the way that he
disavowed jordan peterson he was like
you
did something transphobic you said
something you this you said that and
essentially it was just a list of crimes
against progressivism but i mean that's
the same as an imam coming to me and
saying well you've eaten bacon you've
had you've drunk alcohol you've
fornicated before marriage i'm like okay
i'm not muslim you know these are not my
standards i don't i don't agree that
these are things i should care about and
ethan klein has adopted them
unthinkingly because other people on
twitter these are the these are the
things that the big twitter you know
viral twitter threads and tweets um
highlight and so it's put it into his
mind that these are important things but
are they important things or is there
something more important in ethan's life
like his wife and children perhaps you
know rather than a very tiny fringe
minority of which he probably knows very
few people but this is this is the thing
this is the problem with twitter and so
and you can see this this dramatic
leftward shift in his content and now
he's hosting a podcast with a guy called
hassan [ __ ] for anyone who doesn't know
he's uh he's a literal communist and the
kind of communist that one would call a
tanki
uh he he thinks the soviet union was a
good idea and that america deserved 911.
uh and so
he he explicitly said america is at 911
yes
he had to go
he's the nephew of
genk yuga of the young turks and he was
working at the young turks at times a
couple of years ago and he had to go on
the young turks and with his uncle and
essentially
be told he had to disavow this position
he can't say that america deserved 911.
and the thing is he refused to do so and
now he's no longer at the young turks
because even jank who obviously hates
america himself was like look we can't
just say that you know you can't just
say you know we're americans we're in
america we're not going to say that
america deserves the worst terror attack
has ever experienced uh but hassan for
some reason thinks the isis position is
uh the the jihadi position is more
legitimate than the american position
ethan's got him on a podcast now yeah
it's called leftovers which is a really
stupid name but then they're not very
bright people but the the interesting
thing about this is that hassan looks
like the smart guy next to ethan
but the best parts though the best part
even though he's a literal communist
nathan is basically a communist now
himself uh the best part about it is
their phenomenal success uh their set
costs three million dollars and in the
middle like
between the segments of their thing i
watched an episode of it and they they
have to do like three adverts of uh you
know for buy this product and you'll
grow
i don't know some sort of
anti-capitalist chest hair or whatever
it is they sell
but it's the most hyper capitalist thing
in the world and you can see during the
shilling hassan's face he just looks
like he's dying inside his sight
this just doesn't work
exactly you've got to pay for it all
gotta gotta pay for that three million
dollar mansion that he lives in and uh
so by promoting communism they're
literally being as capitalist as
possible and
dying in on the inside and i i kind of
love to watch it i kind of love because
i've i've never done a shill i've never
promoted a product i've never
had any kind of corporate contract or
anything like that
anything i do i do on a gentleman's
agreement because i think that's
there's something important there right
because it's about not just you are
going to be forced to keep your word but
it's about the desire to keep your word
it shows good will and good faith in
what you do
and so that i think
there's something there but um
but the fact that i've never had to do
the shill and i'm pro-capitalism and
these communists who are constantly
raging about lake state's capitalism are
the ones shilling
shelling their hearts out
it's there's just a beautiful irony so
is ethan are you thinking that ethan's
sort of been passively peered pressured
in just based on what he sees on twitter
i don't think it's peer pressure i just
think that ethan is not really a very
philosophically minded guy and these
people the the the ideology itself and
the people who are the authors of the
main strains of thought within the
ideology are very very smart and what
they've done for the last 50 60 years
probably since since uh the
since post-war uh europe the time of
post-war europe um
they've
established that look
the way the things that work in the
united states
is not going to bring about communism
and therefore we need to undermine this
and deliberately engage in what uh
communist antonio gramsci called a war
of position so we can see that the
society is a very powerful society
it's not going to be overthrown in a
revolution like lenin did against the
provisional government
and so what what they need to do is wear
away the society in order to open up the
possibility of going towards communism
and so for the past i mean
probably
probably nearly 100 years now
that they've been creating memes right
they've been working on ways of
cracking open the contradictions or the
um inconsistencies within our philosophy
is the sort of like classically liberal
enlightenment west and
trying to break it apart slowly but
surely just as if you know you've got
this you've seen the you've seen the um
the videos the viral videos you've seen
on facebook of like some guy in india or
something he's got this giant stone and
he's got like just a couple of
metal um
uh chisels and a hammer and he puts a
couple of them in and then crack the
whole thing splits open right it's that
kind of effect that they're going for
they're like right there's a there's a
contradiction here there's an
inconsistency here there's something
that's just not filled out here if we
just hammer on these bits hard enough
the whole thing starts breaking apart
and that's what they've been doing to us
and they've been doing it very
consciously they know that they're doing
this and they want to do it because
frankly they think that communism is
where we should all be even though
there's never been a good example of
communism and never will be um but it's
it's kind of like the unfinished puzzle
of the enlightenment you know the smart
people look at it and think i can solve
this this will fix all of our problems
but it's nonsense um
but yeah so ethan is essentially um the
victim of that process i was going to
say because i'm always skeptical about
the people that are whatever
at the coal face of this
i'm so non-conspiratorial with the way
that i think but the fact that ethan
klein could be co-opted into some grand
attempt to try and take down the west
just doesn't seem realistic but
it what it seems like what you're saying
is that he's sort of a
willing
ignorant participant like a useful idiot
the problem is uh it's not a conspiracy
um it's all out in the open and i can
just tell you the names of the people
who are doing it and the books in fact
in fact do i have it on my desk yeah
here we go
so
i mean it begins with people like the
frankfurt school which theodor dono uh
hawkheimer marcusa and a bunch of others
um this is dialectic enlightenment where
they're literally trying to figure out
what's gone wrong why haven't we
achieved communism why is capitalism one
and then this this is what's called
critical theory this moves into
uh what we now know as critical race
theory and then that's people that
begins with people like derek bell um
let me let me get up my uh my notes
actually right so you've got derek bell
you've got alan friedman you've got
richard delgado mari
obviously kimberly crenshaw harland
dalton anthony cook you can look all of
these people up i don't have the book
with me it's at work you know it's in
the office otherwise i'd be able to
bring up that huge book it's just called
critical race theory the key writings of
former movement it was edited and
curated by kimberly crenshaw and she's
got a bunch of essays in here and but a
bunch of the essays that she's written
um in harvard law school this was uh
back in 1987 and 1989 i think it was uh
that um she expressly says this but uh i
mean and in
various other writings of critical race
theory you can find this for example
she's got an essay called race reform
and retrenchment transformation
legitimation and anti-discrimination law
and this is where she says and i quote
uh she wants gramski to literally uh she
wants to use the grand scheme tactics to
begin withering away our society uh and
therefore she says she wants to adopt a
legal she the problem is that a legal
strategy will not include registration
redistribution of wealth right that's
what she thinks and so you can see
exactly it is a she's a communist she is
interested in achieving communism and
she is a in the legal
arena the illegal academia and she can't
get the redistribution of wealth that
she's looking for for through american
law because american law is of course
based on classical liberalism which is
fundamentally based on the right to own
property communism of course is that
nobody owns property so this is never
going to happen there's no justification
for it and so what she does is realize
if we can essentially expand the
definition of the words because one of
the things she points out is that look
if i just come in and say right we need
a revolution then all of the all of the
systems are just carrying along happily
and she tries to put that down that's
going to bash her out of the way it's
like we're not having a revolution get
out of here you know we've got a
constitution for example but then she
realized what we need to do and she says
literally
it she says this quote demands for
change that do not reflect the
institutional logic will probably be
ineffective which is true and this is
the demand for revolution it's not going
to work and so what she does essentially
slides into the institutional logic and
expands the definition of the words that
they're using
in order to encompass their antonym now
for example she in this particular essay
uses the example of racism racism she
she gives two definitions the expansive
and restrictive views of racism
what who consents to this who agrees
that there are two definitions of racism
i don't agree with that racism in my
opinion is the conscious act of
discriminating against someone because
of their race because you do not like
their race but that's not her definition
her definition is an outcome that has a
that can be categorized based on races
that shows some kind of difference
i don't agree that's racism but if she
redefines it to be that and then
proliferates this view of what racism is
which is now a systemic structural
everything around us is complicit in
the average white family having more
wealth than the average black family
then suddenly our entire society becomes
racist and now you can see how the
critical race theorists are saying well
we live in a giant racist society it's
like okay but you can never point to an
act of racial discrimination but they
don't care
sorry they don't need to because they've
concept creeped it and expanded it out
yes precisely so is it is it the case
with jordan is he
tainting
the purity of ethan when you look at his
back catalogue
yes uh without a doubt
[Laughter]
and notice how this came unprovoked from
ethan klein as well right so just to
just to quickly finish this all
basically ethan has found himself just
it's he's in this river right that's
been redirected to the critical race
theory view of things the work view
things uh sorry i've got a massive spot
there because the other day i was
reading something i had a spot and i
just kept scratching it and it looks
gross and i'm trying not to scratch it
now um
ethan ethan is is just in the river of
wokeness wokeness is critical race
theory that's what it all comes from and
again kimberly crenshaw's basically the
chief strategist of this because in her
essays she was writing well look it's
not just uh we can do this for black
people and black women and she coined
the term in sectionality because she was
writing an essay about the intersection
of how
the the way that american civil rights
work at the time this was back in the
90s or the 80s uh is that they would
recognize oppression because you're a
black or because you're a woman but they
didn't insect into black women anything
about it this was inevitable that this
would come about you know if you if you
infuse envisage the world that you know
blacks are oppressed or women are
oppressed uh then why couldn't you have
black women being oppressed you know
doubly oppressed you know there's no
reason that this logic wasn't going to
come about at some point and kimberly
crenshaw was the first one to identify
it calling the term in sexuality and
from this she even says well we can do
this with the gay community with the
trans community and this is back in the
80s and 90s she's saying this so you can
see how long these ideas have been on
the pot for on the boil right and it's
just it's not just her of course it's
dozens and dozens of different
left-wing academics communist academics
because they're looking to destroy this
what they call the patriarchy the the
inherited structures of classical
liberal society in the west because
these are the things as gramski says are
preventing the communist revolution and
they're not wrong like they're not wrong
that the fact that we've got families
and business owners and properties and
governments and rules and laws yeah
these are all preventing a communist
revolution that's true that's why we
have them we don't want a communist
revolution we want a prosperous society
where we can feel safe and secure and we
know what's going to happen tomorrow and
we've you know i'm going to wake up and
my car's going to be in the driveway and
things like this because i only you know
that's much more preferable than no one
owning anything and the state having
total domination over everything we have
uh which is not even the end of what
they're aiming for in communism but the
the point is this is the entire basis of
work philosophy and
ethan
is the victim of the memes that the
memetic warfare they've been engaging in
so what they're doing is saying well
look trans rights ethan he's like well i
mean they're human beings of course they
have rights you know everyone has rights
but what's a trans right why would you
bring that up why wouldn't you just say
human right it's exactly it should be
exactly the same thing should it not
except the trans right is something new
now you know it's something
different there are apparently rights
that trans people have that i don't have
for example uh which is implicit in the
construction of the phrase trans rights
anything you know being a bumbling idiot
he's just like well of course i don't
know
of course i believe in this but once you
start going he's putting like a foot in
the river you know and then oh you know
affirmations and people retweeting and
the general sort of radicalizing effect
of twitter getting in bed with other
leftists who then take him down the sort
of mimetic
paths that they
bring you on uh and
now he's like dude and it noticed that
he just comes out and just out of
nowhere no one was saying you know ethan
you have to disavow jordan peace and no
one's saying this this is an old
interview but he just came out i was
like i'm gonna take down that jordan
peterson interviews like
okay no one's making you do that ethan
but you've chosen to do it because
you've accepted a series of premises
that have led you to the conclusion that
actually you used to be a terrible
person and it's like that's weird
because it leaks to me and all the world
like you're the terrible person now like
ethan used to do decent things he used
to actually help people he used to he
used to do a bit of investigative
journalism occasionally and he used to
entertain people and just you know
be an entertainer
he wasn't the active piece of [ __ ] that
he has become like you can see this in
his
like betrayal and deception of stephen
crowder it was just a scummy thing to do
absolutely scummy and the way he's going
after joe rogan the way he's gonna have
john peterson people that i would
consider to be people of high moral
character you know people i've both met
i've had conversations with them they
did not seem in any way deceptive they
seem to exhibit virtue in their daily
lives they have millions of adoring fans
because of their virtues and you've got
this fat communist idiots going they're
bad people
shut up ethan
you're the useful idiot of a bunch of
people who are trying to overthrow the
west frankly
have you heard of the purity spiral do
you know what that is yes i only learned
about that this week so the situation
yeah
well it makes sense like i understand
the circular firing squad sort of
analogy but yeah the fact that over time
ideological groups require the uh
binding of an in-group to be over the
mutual hatred of an out group and the
easiest way to do that is to continually
shave off little elements that allow one
person to go out well look we are now
moral because we're standing on the
shoulders of the people that are no
longer moral and um that really [ __ ]
that increasing sort of zealousness
about ideologies explains so much i love
when uh things piece together like that
and there's a
so one one one thing i've been thinking
about is the concept of ideology um i
mean could you define an ideology
find what ideology is me now right
exactly like i'm not i'm not that's not
a criticism either most people can't i
couldn't you know and i was i was just
out there one day thinking about this
why can't i define what ideology
actually means because i mean you get a
dictionary and get like a very basic
definition it's something more than a
belief structure right it's more than
norms it's more than
yeah so what what the the critical race
theorists there's um there's a chap
called i think it's alan freeman's uh
one of his essays let me just go through
my sorry i've got loads of notes because
they there's literally like 40 essays in
this giant tome of uh all of their ideas
right but uh
they've got like their own theories on
what the world what the world is and how
things mean you know what what things
are
um and one of them has a theory of
ideology and this is not the only person
who has a theory of ideology um but this
this theory is that ideology is a series
of contested ideas
uh that is a battleground for power
games you knows and you're trying to
assert one set of ideas over another win
a series of arguments and
essentially conquer the field
this this was
similar to a theory of ideology from a
conservative philosopher called michael
oakshot who said that it's a an
interlaced an interlocking uh system uh
lattice of ideas that justify the
seizure of power and also these are kind
of a crib of a set of traditions um and
there's a there's a bit of overlap there
so it's all right okay this is it is
interesting how
the very notion that i have a series of
thoughts and that justifies
hurting people
is
just totally pervasive in society
everyone thinks it like all of the left
at the moment they will do what they can
to de-platform to humiliate and this is
something that i can't stand watching
beta left-wing men trying to humiliate
right-wing women it's like that's so
feminist you know but because they think
wrong it's okay and of course you know
the platform anti-fire attacking people
like andy noah and whoever it is
but it's this constant
war that they're engaged in you know
this is the ideologist's war they're
eroding the power and the status and the
position in society of anyone who
opposes them and the the circular firing
squad is something that happens when
they're in their own echo chambers now
it's about status you know how do you
get status well being the person who
professes the most
correct interpretation of the ideology
this this lattice of contestable ideas
you get that so to interject that you
get that uh
ever increasing requirement to adhere to
the tribal norms in conservative circles
as well though right
in
not in quite the same way um there are
because the the problem
is that often what we call conservative
circles are actually not conservative
they're actually uh wig circles or
classical liberal they're they're a set
of ideologies themselves uh take for
example the republicans in america
they're not conservative they have an
ideological agenda they're the product
of a revolution you know a conservative
is someone who is the inheritor of
tradition uh which is
innately anti-revolutionary because of
course you're continuing a long
tradition that has been passed on to you
with the expectation that you will
maintain it look after it and pass it on
to future generations and so you don't
have an ideological agenda you're just
looking at the real world and the way
things are done and you
act accordingly you don't really have
like an agenda for the entire world
you've got a particular thing in a
particular place at a particular time
and you are just preserving it for the
next generation and making sure you're
you sort of polishing it you know you're
buffing it up but you don't have a
series of ideas that can be contested
and attacked based on someone else's
rational thoughts like the british
monarchy is a great example of this why
do we have all this pomp and ceremony
like you can't rationally justify it
because it's the product of
millions of people's inputs over
thousands and a thousand years and
you can't explain it you know it's it's
it's the the inherited wisdom of
generations upon generations of people
is way more than one man could just sit
down and be like right so i'm going to
explain why we do this but we do it
because a we know it works it's lasted
so it must have some value and it's uh
it's an irrational thing it's like it's
a prejudice that we have
but it also has emotional resonance with
us it matters you know this it makes us
feel at home in our world when we see
you know the the the the pomp and
ceremony of the market right okay the
world is properly ordered everything is
as it should be we're gonna watch the
ceremony everyone will do their part
because they're supposed to do the
little part because you know 300 years
ago someone fell over and it became a
habit that now has fallen into the
ceremony and stuff like that
but it it it creates a kind of
um sort of emergent order right that no
one person is in control of and no one
person is designed the american republic
isn't like that you know republicans
aren't like that progressives aren't
like that they have got a series of
basically you know holy books that
people have gone wrong so we're gonna do
this this this this and this that that
that that and then boom we'll have the
perfect system it's like okay
that's one guy with one opinion maybe
he's right but he's probably not let's
be honest and uh you know the closest
we've come to a decent version of that
is the american republic every other
example of this like you know the french
republics which now they're on the fifth
one uh you know the soviet union china
wherever they've turned into terrible
terrible places that have made terrible
terrible mistakes they've got millions
of people killed um and so i'm i'm very
skeptical of ideologists at this point
you know when some when a guy comes
along goes i've got the ideas it's like
so
so what you know i don't care you know i
don't have to listen to them i don't
have to be bound by them and you don't
have any right to hurt me because you've
got an idea you know you don't get to
take things away from me you don't get
to persecute me you don't get to gain
control of the entire country or the
entire world in many cases is what
they're aiming for just because you have
a set of ideas you know this is just you
this does not give you license over me
so just go away you know that's
basically what anyone can turn around
and say to any of these people
and so this this is the difference like
because i know what you mean in like
american republican circles
i know exactly what you mean but listen
to the language that they're invoking
when they do it it's all this kind of
ideologist rhetoric of the constitution
the founding fathers the ideological
revolution that is the united states and
i'm not even saying that that i support
the ideological revolution of the united
states
but it's not conservative you know it's
it's it's classically liberal it's wig
uh which is fine i'm awake um but uh but
it's not it's not the same thing and it
it's this this kind of murky uh
confusion in our thinking that i think
has allowed the progressives to be you
know sit back very very cunningly and be
right i can see how i can get you and
that's how they've come along i think
i want to talk about this paulina
porriskova lady the 56 year old
supermodel that dared to look her age do
you see this
i did a video on it yeah all right okay
yeah so uh pirate's cover was once the
world's highest paid model but as she
hit her 50s she says she was suddenly
invisible now 56 she's leading a new
wave of older women taking their place
in the spotlight and on the catwalk and
flaunting it on instagram in her bikini
what do you think of uh
paulina porriskova carl
i think that nature is a very cruel
mistress
to women very much so
yes to women uh she's she's not overly
kind to men either to be honest but uh
the we get the better end of the deal
out of the two when we get older we do
yeah when we get older but when we're
young we don't you know it's quite rough
actually right
yeah well we're thrown into a world
where we're competing with a bunch of
men who have a bunch of advantages over
us and there's no way of getting these
advantages until a set period of time
has passed so you just sat there right
so there's literally nothing you can do
other than get your head down and get to
work yeah that's all you can do as a man
but women have got a completely reverse
dynamic and
it's kind of unfortunate actually
they're they're in our society they're
they're they they emerge into a society
that doesn't warn them that this doesn't
last forever their birth
they become a woman 18 years old and you
see this all the okay cupid data and
things like that women are most
attractive two men
all men at about 21 years old like every
man will say 21 year old is the most
attractive woman i've seen the same
grasp i've seen the same graphic you're
talking about yeah it's hilarious
whereas women will say you know the
man's the most attractive men will be
roughly their own age as they get older
uh and and peak at about 40 45. um and
so men men have that advantage over
women that women are given a huge amount
of social and sexual power in their
youth
that is just drained away as they age
and
this is not fair but it is a fact and so
with this is what women should be
they should be using their time in their
youth to find the
the best man for them the man they
really want uh and get him into a
long-term relationship uh preferably a
marriage so when they're in their 50s
they have the companion and they have
earned
the the status of being the wife of this
man you know this is not they're not
going to be finding themselves on their
own because at 56
men are not looking for a 56 year old
woman men who are eligible and who are
looking for a partner
do not consider 56 year olds unless
they're a significant amount older than
56. well the thing the thing i saw from
reading that article um this polina lady
is upset because previously she would
walk into a party and everybody would
turn and look at her and she would be
this showstopper and now that's not
happening anymore and younger girls are
doing that you know the reverse is true
the guy at 18 that walks into a room no
one gives a [ __ ] about but at uh 48 when
he's the ceo of a company and he's flown
in on a private jet or he's got other
markers of status or prestige or a claim
or whatever then maybe people will so
over time the um notoriety and value and
prestige that society holds you in is
going to change yes that is that is true
the issue the main issue that i saw with
this is that
the model
was presuming that the thing which gave
her value when she was younger should
still be the thing which gives her value
when she's older and that that felt
really tragic to me because i can see
how i can see how
a girl who enters the world of modeling
who continues to be in that world who is
told that her looks are her primary
contribution to the world and this was a
woman who i think had
two or three children um and had a
husband up until only a couple of years
ago and then got separated um
so this is someone who who's had the
opportunity to cultivate other parts of
her life or the things that she feels
she contributes to the world in a way
which genuinely makes her something that
appreciates with time that doesn't
depreciate with time and the problem is
that and this is true for guys as well i
think anybody that gets to their 30s and
is still primarily taking this their
main source of value to the world from
the way that they look
is
they have invested their resources into
a depreciating asset because over time
that is going to wane and what you need
to try and do is come up with
grace
poise
interest humor yeah all of those things
right these things are going to
appreciate with time these are these are
the things that you can have on your 70
and still crush a room with you know you
can have comedians uh you know your
granddad you don't think about you
you're not bothered about your granddad
walking into a room because he's like
the best looking guy in the room but he
might be the one that's got the most
virtue or wisdom or insight or humor or
balance or whatever it might be
and there's a lie that's sold
from
the media and from consumer society that
the primary value that women have isn't
even their beauty it's their hotness
if you look at the sort of women that we
see
on tv on love island i'm aware that i'm
chilling for this as well um but the the
girls that go on there
not that they're not always so part of
your wisdom don't apologize true uh
not that they're not always they're not
ever beautiful but they're often hotter
than they are beautiful
that's being signaled off of very very
immediate hotness as opposed to timeless
beauty which i think because i mean you
could you could be beautiful in a in a
very conservative dress you know but you
can't be hot in a very conservative
dress you know that's what you're saying
right yeah but but you i i think you've
i think you're making a great point and
the like it's very rare for men to be
able to leverage their attractiveness uh
to any significant degree like you know
that's a very very small percentage of
men who become like you know famous
actors or something in their 20s and
then get you know any woman in the world
that's chris
leo dicaprio's of the world yeah it's
probably not going to be you right so
what you
you're probably about a five out of ten
like you know like me uh and you know
most women are gonna be about five out
of ten but women are more attractive as
they're young and grow less attractive
as they get old and men are less
attractive as they're young and grow
more attractive as the world and this is
just the way that nature plays the game
exactly as you were describing it um but
the and exactly as you say like society
is not preparing women to learn
that i mean i can't even imagine what it
must have been like to be 21 years old
and literally have the world at your
feet you know and i think most men have
no idea what that experience is going to
be like because i was nobody of any
importance and nobody cared about you
know me in any particular way apart from
my friends and family of course you know
no i was not in any way impressive or
important when i was 21 years old unlike
this model who was getting you know
millions of dollars per contract and who
was commanding the room and who's the
very top of society you know and so to
just have that you know just just slowly
fade away until no one cares about me
it's like well yeah but you
essentially were given a gift when you
were young and you didn't as you say
cultivate anything else you thought well
i've got this one thing i don't need to
do anything else whereas i've had to
have this slow laborious and often
depressing ascent to a position where
people actually give a [ __ ] what i have
to say you know and people actually care
whether i'm i'm you know i say this or
that or anything and it's it's a very
privileged place to be but i've worked
really hard for it you know and it's
it's not something can just be taken
away by you know my my growing older
unless i go totally seen out of course
but then i think i've got other problems
at that point um you know it's it's
something that and i i can it's a it's
this this thing that i can think
continue to cultivate that will continue
to get better whereas she's out of
options now you know she can't do that
and we don't prepare women for this
inevitability it is inevitable that you
will get old you'll become saggy you
will get wrinkly and you'll become
infertile and then men will not be
interested in you so if you based your
success off the interest of the opposite
sex that's eventually going to stop
and you need to be prepared for that and
most most thrall of human history every
civilization knew this and accepted this
as a part of the sort of teleology of
being a woman this is what's going to
happen so we and we had social roles for
women to fall into you know to grow into
after the the beauty had
faded somewhat you know you'd be married
you'd be a pillar of the community you'd
be involved in some sort of social club
or you know a charity you'd be doing
something you and then you you you go to
a mother and then to a grandmother and
so now you're you know as an older woman
you still have plenty of value to your
children and your grandchildren there
are still people who care about you and
don't run this other woman has children
and doubtless have grandchildren so she
she at least still has that life path
open but a lot of women these days are
not having children but even even even
the conversation that she brings up
there she doesn't say
she doesn't mention them does she
precisely no it's weird isn't it because
you think she'd take solace in the fact
that she at least has a family who love
her you know but she's uh trying to gain
the attention of men like she did when
she was in her 20s it's like that period
of your life is over you need to come to
terms with that because it's kind of
embarrassing granny that you're posting
bikini shots on instagram like what are
you doing i don't want my grandmothers
to be doing that i want them to have a
bit of dignity and self-respect and to
to grow into the role that nature has
expected of you you know because you
can't avoid it
as she's found out to her chagrin and
you're going to be you're going to be
defeated by someone who is
30 years younger than you now which she
complains about in the article there's
no getting around it but she was more
than happy to take the success of that
when she was beating the 56 year olds
when she was 21. yeah i you know i i'm
very very sort of
not cautious but it is it is sort of uh
cautious of trying to be sympathetic to
the situation that
women have got themselves to that place
perhaps and they didn't know if she'd
known when she was 21 that if i'd
continue down this road when i'm 50 by
the time i'm 56 i'm going to be
miserable she probably would have done
things differently so partly you think
well you know you're culpable to some
extent but also nobody warned you and i
think it is important to to try and have
these warnings out there for women
i i'm i'm actually a bit more
sympathetic than that because i do think
that
you are a product of your environment to
a great degree and if you're in an
environment that that venerates youth
and doesn't have any
time or consideration for
wisdom and age then you end up in a
position where you just don't have
anyone putting that in your mind you
know that's just not a thought that you
ever have and there's no reason for you
to have had it you know
and so it's
it's kind of cruel frankly what i think
our society does to women um as they
grow older and you get now you're
getting now loads of millennial wine
aunts who are getting into their 40s and
i i do these segments on the podcast all
the time because whenever you know in
whatever vogue or bustle or whatever the
women's magazine is where it's i'm 40
years old i have three degrees i earn a
hundred thousand pound dollars a year
i've got two cats and i can't find a man
what's going on
who told you that you would be able to
find a man with those credentials you
know why would you think you're in your
40s you'd start settling down and
finding a husband and kids it's not good
for either
gender no no it's not good for men
that's all it's not good for men because
there is a group of career women who are
chasing education employment and status
throughout their 20s and 30s which means
that they're unavailable and then by the
time that they do get there most women
don't want to be in a relationship with
a man that earns less than them and is
less uh educated which means that
they've competed themselves out of their
own dominance hierarchy because there's
no one above and across the men that
they're looking for are around their age
but the men that are around their age
are looking for women that are 10 years
young 10 years younger than them yeah
and also the dating pool is very narrow
at that point you know very very narrow
and and but it's it's more than that as
well though because think about what
they're doing in the process of coming
up to that point where they're like uh
you know i i can't find a man and why
isn't society paying attention i and i i
hear the word invisible being used a lot
by these women uh this is a constant and
multiple times she uses it in that
article and i've seen it in other places
it's like i'm invisible and it's like
yeah you're like me
i'm invisible like i just walk around
and get on with my life i don't have
like women like looking at me and you
probably do but i i don't have women's
looking at me as i go past you know this
is what life is like um but the the the
sort of like
not necessarily the model obviously
because she's not competing in an arena
where men would also be competing but
the the four-year-old wine aunt who's
the you know the deputy ceo of a company
or something
her working in the corporate world is
her occupying a position that a man
could have been occupying and so she's
knocking men a man down on that sort of
social scale and so when you've got
millions of women in the workplace all
like being girl bosses well you're
generally elevating the status of men in
society you think okay well you know men
deserve it i don't care i'm a feminist
it's like sure sure yeah
but that's my point you're elevating the
level of men in society for your own
personal gain getting to the pinnacle
and then being like i'm lonely where are
all the good men at yeah i'm lonely
where are all the good men i can't find
a man it's like yeah well you were
selfish you didn't consider what men
need to be attractive to you let alone
for their own self-esteem and for their
own vitality and prosperity you were
just like me me me me me and then you're
still me me me me i know and all these
guys have just checked out society
they're just you know playing their
xboxes living in shared accommodation
with each other until they're well into
their late 30s drinking beer every night
and working crappy jobs and they're fine
you know because they actually don't
need much to get along but i think if
you asked any of them they would say
yeah i would like a wife you know i
would like a family i would like kids i
would like a successful career i would
like to have the prestige of being the
breadwinner in the household you know
it's not that i'm saying women can't
work or anything like that but like
be considerate where's the good will
from either side you know and it seems
to be the lack of goodwill on the part
of the career woman has just
ruined the way our civilization works
and it's not good for the men it's not
good for the women and the results of
this are smacking us in the faces right
now there's nothing we can do about it
now honestly man like the more that i
think about this
the more
i feel like we might be totally [ __ ]
like it just feels like you know that
meme of the dog in the house and the
house is on fire and he's just smiling
through the beginning of the end this is
fine like if men don't kill themselves
they're exiting education and society
and family life at the highest rates
ever women are frantically pursuing
careers only to discover that they're
unable to find a partner that they're
attracted to and then jump on meds at 40
years old the highest uh percentage at
the highest group uh the huge meds are
between white women between 40 and 45
years old and then the people who want
kids can't find a partner that does as
well birth rates declining faith in the
leaders in the news organizations
non-existent and everyone's just about
sufficiently sedated not to notice or
care that it's going on
that's a precise and accurate summary of
how the west has declined and will
collapse yes
[ __ ]
i know
it's tr and do you know what's worse
right is that
the few that are in the generations that
are coming up now
are totally [ __ ] by leftist ideology
um the way that women young women view
men is evil it is purely as a
transaction as in they are essentially
prostitutes every single one and they
don't even realize it and the young men
what do you mean you women as trophies
you know women are now just again
they're not people they don't view each
other as people
the the thing
a human being is a three-dimensional
thing it's it's got a material component
and then it's got an emotional component
and the spiritual components you know
like the the metaphysics we ascribe to
what is a person and the thing that we
consider you know you're not just chris
you're uh you know you're not just the
body of chris you are you know a
personality you know i'm considerate of
you when i'm talking to you and things
like this you know when you when you
message me on facebook hey man how's it
going you know so
i don't just send you a link to my only
fans right and ask you to subscribe but
that's how a generation of women have
been trained by feminists to view men
in order not to be oppressed by the
patriarchy right and so these women i
think have been essentially made unable
to love men as people right they don't
really see them as people they they view
them as a kind of competit a competition
like
competitors on a playing field and the
young men don't know what to do and so
now they're just following their base
instincts of i should try and have sex i
should try and see a woman naked
you know and therefore that's flattening
a woman down to merely her biological
components now it's not even romance you
know no it's not about falling in love
it's about send nudes yeah
it's
objectification from men to women and
commodification of uh men from women
like
yeah is it was it you that said um
in the same way that porn has skewed
men's expectations of women only fans
have skewed women's expectations of men
i've cited it by you uh even if it
wasn't so it may well take it because
but because i totally agree with that
statement i may have said that um
because it's it's awful how
only fan says
it's commodified being a girlfriend
right that's the thing so everyone
thinks oh you know you're just getting
nudes it's just like porn it's like it's
not just like emotional
i've been watching a bunch of youtube
videos by women who do only fans who
explain what they're doing on only
fantastic i've never used them you know
god forbid my wife would kill me um
but
so it basically it seems like you're
sort of like an online artificial
girlfriend service you know and the sort
of romantic nudes that you'd send to one
another and sexy posts and stuff they
send to like you know 5 000 men or
however many years like right
that's not good is it you know that's
that's pretending to have an intimate
relationship with thousands of different
men and it's not surprising that there
have been recently a bunch of only found
models who have been murdered by
subscribers no way yeah no no we
recently did a video in fact it should
be out on podcast delicious uh already
by the time this goes up uh it's not out
yet though but um yeah we've got you
know three examples in the last week
where subscribers have murdered these
people and there was one guy who had
gone to florida stalked an only fans
model murdered her and then
written on like the walls i shouldn't
have come it's her fault for making me
love her or something like that and
stuff like this and it's just like look
this is warped what it is to be in a
romantic and sexual relationship like
pretending that we can just commodify
these things and that's all a human
being needs is not true
both people on both sides can detach
their emotions from the situation
that the guy isn't going to feel
anything more than well he knows that
this is just messages he knows that this
is just work and the same as the
yeah precisely they can't switch that
off they can't switch that emotional
situation off but but for the the sort
of gen z woman
men are merely a mode of transaction
because they've been indoctrinated by
feminists in their schools and just in
the culture at large to view men as
being part of an oppressive structure
and they have to be on their guard
against men you know men are here to
take something from you men are
dangerous to women you know
you've got to
you've got to view them as a thing to
get money from well if they're the enemy
then defeating the enemy makes sense but
the other side of this is
i don't know
i
i wonder what it teaches women
not only the women that do only fans but
even the women that know that other
women do only funds what does it teach
them about what their worth is we've
literally just said if you enter the
world and your primary source of value
is your looks or your sex appeal
this is a depreciating asset and you
need to be very very careful um this is
the richest i wouldn't like to guess
there is a huge swath of some of the
richest people in the uk and in america
that are women that are probably getting
their money directly from taking their
clothes off and sending photos to people
that pay them for it and that's what
other women are thinking as well so
by osmosis almost there's these role
models of women that are in a society
that says girls you can be a girl boss
too clap back don't settle for less be a
boss [ __ ] all of this stuff be a career
woman and also some of the most
successful career women that you know
are the ones who are using
base the lowest form
of female value to the world
as their way to climb this dominance
hierarchy like it's not good i don't
think it's good for women i don't think
it's good for men either it's terrible
for society in general you know it's
it's
again it it's it's teaching women that
men aren't
important and
unique things because like the the the
root of every relationship every
relationship is unique right ev and and
no one else can have that relationship
with you your relationship my
relationship to you my relationship to
my wife my relationship with my sons
they'll never have that relationship
ever again right you'll always have a
different relationship with someone else
and relationships are like
a chain you know like a rope you know
and if you don't if you don't like keep
it in good check if you don't you know
do the things that the other person
appreciates and if they don't
reciprocate and do the things you
appreciate then the relationship fades
and frays and ends up breaking you know
and then there could be other ways of
breaking it but like
it's something you have to nurture
something you have to take care of and
something that is what i think is the
the genuine content of the human
experience and i think that this is why
if you go back a hundred years people
were so much poorer but they were not on
antidepressants they weren't all
depressed they weren't all sad because
they had their families they had their
friends they had their social life they
had a reason to live you know i've got
to go to over to mavis house and and
pick up her groceries for her you know
and stuff like this you feel good about
doing something good for someone else
maybe so probably make you a cup of tea
when you get there and you have a nice
little chat and things like this like
this these these relationships are the
genuine the what makes life worth living
you know ostracization used to be a
punishment you know and now people are
literally just ostracized on their
phones thinking god i hope twitter gives
me some likes today from who you don't
know you don't know any of these people
you know some men also are choosing to
ostracize themselves yeah consciously
you know that's what mgtow is what are
those guys in the apartment blocks in
china or japan there's a particular name
of all man yeah them plant man or
whatever it is um and
you know these are guys that are
consciously choosing to just exit
society in the way that we would
typically see it
what do you think do you think that
celebrating
family values and life is under attack
or is it just eroded as a byproduct of
modern society or is it a blend of both
or something different
if if we go back to what we were saying
about the communists looking at the
sturdy structures of our society uh we
can see that it has been a conscious
attack by certain people uh by critical
theorists by communists and it has been
going on for quite some time but this
requires complicity on our parts
happiness with pleasure
and you
consider anything that's non-material to
be non-valuable
then you end up at the place we are at
now where it's just about satisfying the
dopamine rush in your own brain constant
consumption you have to consume on your
phone you have to consume food eat the
sugar you know take the drugs drink the
alcohol whatever it is have have lots of
sex you know with with random people who
cares you know what difference it makes
and if that's happiness which i don't
agree that it is i agree i think that's
pleasure then that's that's a purely
materialistic outlook uh whereas
happiness i think and in previous eras
happiness is defined as something that
is not material it's not physical i
can't give you something that will make
you happy but you'll know you're happy
when you feel it you know and you'll
feel it because it's a state of affairs
you know you don't it's not one
particular instance or i'll take this
pill and then i'll be happy i'll drink
this drink and i'll be i'll feel you
know happy
it's something that is you know
essentially what we call that i guess
satisfaction you know you just think no
i'm happy you know i don't
i don't want to change my life i'm just
going to carry on doing the things i
habitually do and i look around myself
i've got my you know my my particular
case i've got my wife my kids my
business my job my my studies my my my
warhammer you know and i'm very happy
i'm very happy i love everything that i
get to do in my life you know and i
don't
there at no point do i begrudge any of
it even when some of it's hard and it's
difficult you know even when i have to
change my one-year-old's nappies or
something i don't ever begrudge it it's
never chore you know uh and but no it's
not all pleasurable you know but i it is
it does
it is making me satisfied and it is
making me happy and this is a general
sort of state of affairs over time a
continuum that could be broken i mean
don't get me wrong you know if if my
family god forbid died in a car crash or
something then that would be broken you
know but it's not something that can
just be uh given to me by
a product right it's not something that
can be given to me by a service or a
product or you know anything like that
it's
and it can't just be taken away by a
lack of those things you know and and
we've completely misunderstood what it
is to be a whole and complete complete
and happy human being and it's going to
be very uncool to try and reclaim that
but on the plus side
i don't take any depression pills i
don't get a therapy you know i don't
have to worry about any of this i never
sat around going god i wish something
would happen so my life wasn't [ __ ] you
know i never think anything like that
i'm always oh god i hope nothing happens
so it ruins what i've got you know i i'm
you know then and then suddenly you
realize why i'm now a conservative
you know i've got everything i want yeah
this is why families are innately
conservative uh you know i don't i don't
want to ruin the state of affairs
young people have been programmed though
not just to avoid that state of affairs
by the materialistic culture in which we
found ourselves and again i think you
can
directly link things like critical
theory to this process
but they they are now
and unenviably in a position where
and and this is something i get from a
lot of young men because like a couple
of years ago i was like look this is
what you need to do lads you know get
yourself a wife get yourself kids get
yourself a house get yourself a job get
on with it and a lot of them are like
yeah okay that's easy for you to say
because you're already married you know
your wife isn't a gen z zoomer
and isn't only fans you know like this
is easy for you to say because you had
the pick of women who were not
essentially spoiled by the materialistic
culture of the of the modern era um
but now these guys i mean
i wouldn't date a woman who had only
fans i wouldn't date a woman who took
loads of nude photos of myself and they
were all just all over the internet all
the time but not all not all women it's
a very small percentage of women that do
do that
i don't know i don't know if it is and i
and it's not just that those it's the
attitude as well it's the
the the way they view men is not as
potential life partners because they
have been trained by feminists to say
hey you can have it all be the girl boss
you know sleep around as much as you
want i mean
let's say that they're not all
well-known fans sure but i mean what
their body counts you know like by the
time a woman's 25 it's probably not
insignificant at that point and there
are lots of young men who tell me i get
messages about this all the time from
different areas of the world but they're
just like look it's just there are just
no women that i would think of as
suitable partners for marriage and to
become a wife and and i'm just like okay
well
that's terrible that's just really
terrible i don't have a solution i don't
have an answer and it's going to be
really uncool to say well look young
women basically have to use their time
at their peak attractiveness to find the
man of their dreams and get married and
settle down with him you know see him as
a human being fall in love with him you
know
that's not what's being pushed no in
culture it's about you know i think
by 2030 you're going to have two women
for every one man at a four-year u.s
college
and again as we said earlier on if
you've got that hypergamous nature where
women are going to date up and across
that means that you have double the
number of women competing for that
number of men are you familiar with the
sex ratio hypothesis do you know this
no it's quite logical when you think
about it so um
in a
local area where you have an abundance
of women or an abundance of men relative
to the other sex you see changes in
mating patterns
so if you have an abundance of men you
see an increase in long-term mating you
see a
increase in sexual violence you see
women being more selective more choosy
and waiting longer to have sex
when the reverse happens and you have a
surplus of women and a scarcity of men
you see that women are
having sex sooner there are more casual
relationships there are fewer um
sexual aggressive aggressive encounters
um but what that shows first off that's
[ __ ] fascinating and this just
happens right no one's thinking this
through consciously or very few people
are but this means that human sexuality
responds to its local ecology
yeah
how [ __ ]
fascinating is that the fact that your
sexual
proclivities
will
alter
just based on what you're sensing now
maybe a tiny little part of it might be
conscious right and you'll think oh
actually like there's a lot of girls
here and that means if i don't maybe
sleep with this guy on the third date
then he's maybe going to forget about me
because i know that those are the girls
around here or whatever but obviously
the implication of this is that in
colleges where you are having an ever
increasing number of women and ever
decreasing number of men you have women
that are no longer able to get the sort
of relationship that they want
and not only that as well when they
leave
they will and i can't think of a more
delicate way of putting this
uh they will have effectively debased
their own purity
as well and this is this is something
that women have to understand that men
really care about men do not want a
woman who has run through by the time
she leaves university that is not what
they're looking for that is not someone
they're going to make their wife they
want they want preciousness
exclusivity and specialness they want to
think that they are essentially
conquering an undiscovered country with
their wife you know they want it to be
all of theirs and none of anyone else's
they want this this and this creates a
kind of magical state of affairs in the
mind of the man
and you have to if you're a smart woman
and you want to get the guy of your
dreams you will essentially um maintain
your purity as
as best you can and again it's the sort
of thing what hang on
very much like what my conservative
christian grandfather would have said
and say yeah
and he had that tradition for a reason
you know that was true then it's true
now and you're unmarried approaching 40
and on depression medication as you go
and see your [ __ ] therapist all right
you know they your grandmother didn't
have this problem she wasn't hoe when
she was young she got married to your
grandfather when the other 22 and
they're still married now you know but
again with this like to try and sing the
song of sympathy for women it's not like
it's not i don't think up until really
now anyone's been warning women about
this you know sexual revolution wasn't
too long ago birth control
yeah
yeah but i mean who's stepping in and
saying
darling are you bringing another boy
home um no one's stepping in like that
yeah maybe she'll be on patrol you know
this is okay this is not good but you
are right and i i i agree with you know
it's
there has been a
total
total
dropping of the ball when it comes to
understanding the nature of reality of
the relationships between the sexes i
mean even even the pope is telling
people that they need to have more kids
did you see that he's yeah he's right
having pets is selfish why because your
pet will not look after you or someone
else and this so this is another thing i
was i'm thinking about a lot right
so i was thinking look i think we
actually
do have a moral obligation to have
children because we are expecting there
to be people around to do the things
that we want done as in you're like yeah
well i'm gonna get my my retirement
money okay but someone's gonna have to
pay for that you know so you're gonna
have to have a body working to pay for
the retirement money you've got okay
well i don't need kids i'm just gonna go
to a retirement home okay and who's
gonna run that home
your other people's kids someone
exactly other people's kids you're
expecting someone else to have done the
work to have engaged in the labor to
have raised the person
to you to then sort of like you know
parasitically sort of like yeah well
i've got money here's this money come
and do so but i mean is that going to be
enough for them to be like yeah but i'd
rather look after my own mum
even if i don't get your money you know
because i mean i would like to think
that you know when i'm old and infirm my
kids would rather look after me because
i love them and took care of them and
raised them well uh rather than going
off to something because they [ __ ]
owe you carl that's why because you owe
me but because we there's a there's a
there's a thick relationship there this
this concept that's not just the
materialistic about the thing about
money there's love there you know
there's a desire to make sure that the
person who looked after them when they
were young is looked after when they're
older and i'll do that for my parents
you know god god forbid they ever need
that you know my parents are actually
still quite healthy and active so that's
good but like you know when the time
comes i'll do the right thing and my
hopefully my kids will do the right
thing and the the selfish cat mother who
now is expecting my kids to be to be
able to pay them to work for them well
let's hope that they're willing or else
you are just going to be there in your
own unchanged [ __ ] you know where you
can't move no one no one has any
obligations to you that's the thing it's
about bonds of obligation and they're
they are selfishly expecting other
people to have obligations to them it's
like sorry no one does no one needs to
look after you and you're
again just the pope is right you're
being very selfish saying well it's a
i'm it's a lot of work to raise kids
yeah it's a lot of work but it's also
really really rewarding and it rounds
you out as a human being like you learn
things from being a parent that you
can't learn from being a pet owner you
know and you're you're essentially
absconding your position in the great
chain of civilization you know if you
like every individual is the the result
of a lineage that goes back like a
billion years
you know to the very very first
organisms to you and you're like yeah so
i don't need to carry on that chain i
can just abolish all of that i'm just
going to live off other people's effort
and energy it's like
you selfish [ __ ] what makes you think
you have the right to just be like yep i
don't need to do anything about
upholding this civilization by producing
future generations for it i'm the sort
of person who's going to get myself
sterilized i'm going to sit there and
drink my wine and live off the fruits of
this like some sort of conqueror it's
like no and this this is a totally
unsustainable attitude it's not gonna
last you're gonna be miserable and
you're a really selfish piece of [ __ ] i
don't know if it's a moral obligation
but i definitely think that it's an
optimal way for society to move forward
okay let me let me stop you there right
i don't give a [ __ ] about what's optimal
you know it is a moral obligation
because all their life
they relied on the
that other people had done and if they
think that they can just inherit all of
this
and say i'm just going to take take take
take take then that makes them selfish
which is a moral judgment it is a moral
obligation
interesting
i've been thinking about this a lot i
can tell yeah i can tell is this what
keeps you awake at night wrong with us
there's there's nothing wrong with it it
does there's nothing wrong with us
asserting these sort of deep concepts
that we have naturally in our language
you know things like betrayal deception
selfishness you know we don't have to
just go for the sort of thin scientific
term that's like well it's optimal is it
yeah you know is it
i don't care that's really interesting
like talking in
what almost sounds not medieval but
certainly more grand
terms
more it's relational language yeah right
every every every you know when you when
you say you're selfish you're saying
there are two people involved and
there's a relationship between them and
that should have been a certain way but
it's been betrayed or undermined or
something like that i've just realized
that i don't
i don't see that sort of language used
pretty much at all
on the internet i very rarely talk about
betrayal
in
obligation
belonging you know none of this stuff
and i wonder i've noticed this trend on
twitter that let's say that it's dunk
it's just a dunk fest right everyone's
just trying to get one over on somebody
else whenever someone says something
that say that there's a conflict back
and forth between two people whenever
someone says something about the other
person the the in vogue thing to do
is to come up with some dry witty quote
tweet response yeah it's never and even
the people that are in the comments
below that are trying to defend the
person that the other person's just
taking the piss out of
it's very rarely
saying
this is
out of order this is beyond the pale
this is too much it's always trying to
play some sort of lexical game to make
the original tweet look bad very rarely
do people go out of their way to say
look this is this is too much what
you've said is
deplorable it's betrayal it's et cetera
et cetera it's the hobbesian state of
man against man
you're gonna have to explain that to me
what's this right so uh
uh hobbs was uh thomas hobbes i think he
is thomas uh was um very early in latin
philosophy was like look man in the
state of nature his life was nasty
brutish and short and for some reason
the early enlightenment thinkers all
thought that like human beings were like
atomized individuals running around the
woods uh and then you had some who like
well they were constantly at war with
each other and some that said well
they've never talked to each other and
and you know various other uh
conceptions of it and then the idea is
that well they would come together to
form a society from this atomized state
of nation now that never existed
obviously uh it's it's at best a thought
experiment and at worst
[ __ ] ludicrous um
but it underpins all of the thought that
dominates our world today you know the
way that we you know the classical
liberalism the progressivism the
communism all of it is underpinned by
this idea that that's what we used to be
like and that was never true we always
used to live in tribes like chimps do
now you know there were deep
relationships between these you know the
members of the tribes and that's always
been the way it's been from before we
were humans archaeology bears this out
um but the the point is that you had the
you had two conceptions right you had
the french conception from rousseau in
which the oh well you know of course man
just felt pity for his fellow man and so
you know if ever he saw another man in
the woods who was hurt he would just
feel bad about it
unlikely given
the way that we can see the world is or
you had hobbs view which was man was
brutish and evil and savage and he would
just rapaciously take what he could and
then get away with whatever was possible
and civilization makes us better than
our animal cells our primitive selves
whereas from the french view that's the
english view the french view is
civilization makes us worse than our
primitive cells our primitive cells
don't don't do bad things and uh
that twitter appears that to to bear out
the hobbs in uh the hobbesian point as
in no one on twitter really has any
relation to one another you just set up
your account and suddenly you're in the
woods on twitter in this state of nature
where it's all against all and
everyone's dunking on each other
constantly and no one cares about anyone
else because no one's got any obligation
to anyone else on twitter none no
no no
understanding that like for example i
have an obligation to my neighbor you
know everyone knows they have an
obligation to their neighbor not to uh
play their music really loud late at
night not i mean there might be a law
against but even though it wasn't law
against it you'd be like i'm not gonna
do that because that'd be rude right
they live next to me therefore we have a
relationship as neighbors even though
neither of us chose this relationship
and we could break it by simply moving
and that doesn't even need to mean much
you know but there's still that station
in life that is a neighbor and you've
got an obligation to a neighbor and you
know this this is just you know
something you inherit in the culture
that you live in and grow up in with
intuitively
but that doesn't exist on twitter and so
it's just an evil savage thing of people
just dunk don't don't and the the
the dunks are just a replacement for
fistfights you know that's what they are
and you get the same emotional response
from doing that as you do from actually
fighting um
and so this it's this awful awful place
but nobody has any obligation to anyone
else because no one views themselves as
part of the same community and it's only
in the sort of in
and you've got like the factions that
are formed on twitter you know
like x twitter is you know whatever
feminist twitter whatever and that's
where you get the feelings of betrayal
where it's an in-group
and this is what we have failed to
really understand i think
it's we the the relational language is
what means it's baked into our our
language and it describes the things
that are truly worthy and this is where
all drama comes from you know betrayal
you know revenge all of these sort of
you know very deep thick emotional
concepts are what dramas are based on
this is just what east enders is you
know on a constant rolling basis
of oh you know someone
lied to that and stole from that and
hurt that but it's all of these you know
and you can go back anywhere you know
shakespeare go back to ancient tragedies
this is all what these things are about
it's all about the relationships of man
with other men or women
what do you think the future of
mainstream media looks like because i'm
i'm pretty trusting well i'm pretty
trusting usually of the people in power
and like i say i'm not usually
i am dude two years ago i was right two
years ago
i was i like that well i was yeah man
the last two years has
completely eroded and annihilated any
sense of trust that i have not only in
mainstream media but also in
institutions and the powers that be like
it's just a a
really lethal cocktail of
neglect
malice and incompetence
like all sort of swirled together but
is there still a swath of people that
have faith
in
these mainstream media and is it the
older generation that pretty soon are
going to you know within a couple of
decades and maybe not going to be there
anymore and we're now going to have
no
institutions no uh media that mainstream
media that the people that are coming
through are prepared to trust
it seems to me there's the older
generation that is more skeptical of the
institutions at the moment
uh the sort of radicalized boomers who
are voting for brexit and trump
who are just like you know what no this
is [ __ ] i don't like this we're
getting out you know
eject um and that that seems to me that
the the the and
god bless they're the ones who did the
right thing the problem i have are the
zoomers and the millennials who don't
know any different
and don't have any framework for
legitimacy outside of
the power of the state and the
institution uh the this is this is the
worst thing about um
intersectionality and what it's done
having proliferated through our schools
and through our cultures and through our
institutions
i'm not sure what we could say it's
proliferated through the schools yet you
know oh it absolutely has i mean they
got to the stage
oh yeah these people are adults now
i've i've had to have these
conversations with my 11 year old
daughter where she's come home but like
i think i'm bi it's like
what oh well i'm really worried you know
i'm part of the lgbt community i'm
really worried about transphobia she's
11. you know
it's it's everywhere it is everywhere
and this is not something that we can
take lightly because one problem that we
have is that the entire thing is based
on the worship of power the you can't
define anything without power like
racism is power plus privilege you know
blah blah blah blah power is a component
of everything that they conceive of and
if you are expressly critiquing power
relations and saying if there is a power
imbalance then there is oppression and
therefore this is illegitimate then you
have made illegitimate the relationship
between mothers and daughters fathers
and sons you know between teachers and
students between the prime minister or
the president and the population you
know if all of these become illegitimate
then why would i uphold any of them you
know it's all about the and
the
and if the only legitimating factor is
the raw exercise of power and if that's
literally again we've flattened it down
to just the material so there's not it's
not that we've got obligation to these
people and they have obligations to us
which is how it's been like the feudal
view of the world as in the king had an
obligation to his subjects you can go go
go read like robin hood poems and stuff
like this the the problem with king john
is not
any one thing but it's the fact that his
interests and his obligations are not
being met as the king and this is like
robin hood is a deeply reactionary story
like he's not a revolutionary he's not a
socialist what he's saying is the king
is not obligated he's not upholding his
obligations to the peasants in uh in a
in a loving way he's not acting like
their father you know
and
so
if we've if we've annihilated all of
that and reduced it down to purely the
material exercise of power then great
okay now what legitimizes anything well
it's strength you know that's it and if
generations are coming up who don't
understand that there are moral factors
outside of the pure exercise of power
then all they'll consider to be true is
strength power that's the very beating
heart of fascism that's what the
fascists believe that the state is a god
that creates the civilization under it
and imbues the civilization with its
rights and so in fact this is a great
point i wanted to bring up with you like
what's a human right
define a human right where do they come
from what are they anchored in right and
it seems
[ __ ] nothing
and you can tell this by people like
jeremy corbyn who like broadband is a
human right
what does that [ __ ] mean did he say
that yes
yes jeremy corbyn quote broadband is a
human right
what does that mean what does it [ __ ]
mean food water shelter health care none
of these things are huge you're missing
broadband off the bottom of maslow's
hierarchy of needs
absolutely it's the very basic need you
know below
shelter and food and water
i mean
what are you gonna do without it right
but seriously he said this and it's just
like okay what the [ __ ] are you talking
about when you say human right you know
it seems to be whatever's in the front
of his mind at the time as a human right
and it's the same with bernie sanders
and any of these communists because
essentially they take the same position
so look human rights are constructed by
the power structures they are whatever
the people in charge say they are
therefore put the socialist in charge
and he will say that
housing food and water and broadband is
all human rights and you'll be given all
of these things by the state
like the state was [ __ ] god and it's
like okay i don't really believe in
human rights as this conception of it uh
there are other views on rights but they
aren't you know like this uh you know i
believe in negative rights where they're
in imbued in us by nature because i'm
not religious and i don't think it was
god but uh but this is a different
conversation we're in a different
paradigm now and all of these young
people have been
brought up to believe that health care
can be a human right that food can be a
human right the shelter can be a human
right so there is no
moral there is no intellectual
legitimate you know it means nothing
human rights are whatever we say they
are and that means essentially the party
is always right
that's the problem and this is deeply
concerning i don't think there's any
hope for liberty while we allow these
people to control the discourse and
things i don't even know how we can go
start invalidating almost everything
that was done under these auspices like
the healthcare is a human right it's not
end of conversation it is an entitlement
i learned this really interesting
insight about ideological beliefs
recently talking about ideologies so the
usefulness of an absurd ideological
belief is a form of tribal signaling it
signals that the ideology is more
important to the person than reason
itself it's a display of loyalty to your
allies and a threat display to your
enemies it's not about what's true
it's about how does this make me look to
my tribal in-group and out-group so it's
the commodification of beliefs as well
and one of the things that i thought
that was really interesting there is it
it becomes almost like a badge of honor
sometimes to hold increasingly extreme
and absurd beliefs and this happens on
both sides i don't think that this is in
any way
unique to one side or another and um
yeah i just thought that that was really
interesting that you wear your beliefs
ideas
yeah well no no you're absolutely right
because if you think about it like
they're holding to a set of again this
this lattice of ideas but that doesn't
what's that got to do with the world
like that's not reality that's a set of
ideas they're put together and said
right this is important and now the
closer i adhere to these ideas
the more morally correct i am the more
politically correct i am but reality has
been left far behind here reality might
not reflect these ideas at all
and so you get absolute lunatic takes
that have got nothing to do with the
real world being lauded on places like
twitter as being
perfect as being good as being the the
the height of prestige
and the thing is what has this person
done
i've claimed a really extreme position
that you know fits in with this lattice
of ideas
okay
how much effort was that you know how
how much sweat and tears and toil was it
for were to achieve this
moral virtue that is
saying something really extreme you know
you didn't build a house you didn't
climb a mountain you didn't raise a
child you didn't construct a building
you you said something on the internet
you know it's amazing that that gives
people cred so roll it forward for me
mainstream media what do you think the
future has in store
oh um oh god the main the
the problem they have is people like joe
rogan
who wildly popular i i learned the other
day that joe rogan's audience is about
24 years old on average which is not
good for them but it is good for
everyone else because joe rogan is a
decent human being and he is a human
being for a start you know he's not just
a liar
um it's not good it's especially not
good for left-wing media you get people
like uh tucker carlson and the fox news
is the
the majority of the old mainstream media
at this point it's pretty much the only
game on the right by
like by by people tuning into their
shows but they're they're bound to be an
older audience you know joe's is quite a
young audience but um no it's not good
and the thing is i i you don't want to
make like hard and fast predictions but
we're seeing just a constant decline in
viewership i mean cnn apparently after
trump left it wasn't the stat that was
going around like they'd lost 90 percent
of their audience i don't know yes oh
well i i i saw one that was 40 and one
was 90. so we'll get from the 90s it
sounds more extreme uh no i but they've
lost a huge chunk of their audience and
it's because what who are they serving
you know who are they serving they're
they're not serving the actual interests
and needs of the people who they want to
watch whereas someone like joe rogan is
you know someone like you or something
like mia you know we're
talking about things that might help
those people rather than trying to
enforce an institutional gated narrative
where it's like look the powers that be
want you to believe this thing believe
it
what's my investment you know why would
i care why would i want to watch it and
i don't think they know that that's what
they're doing and i don't think they
know how to escape this paradigm they
don't serve anyone other than the
institutions themselves and so the
people who are deeply invested in
left-wing politics and the preservation
of the institutions will watch them and
support them
but everyone else is just getting on
with their lives it's just not going to
bother and so
i don't know what else we can really do
other than enjoy the ride as they
continue to fail
but you know i don't i don't think they
can
maintain themselves indefinitely on this
trajectory
carl benjamin ladies and gentlemen thank
you for coming on mate i always
appreciate it i'm really really happy
for any time how everything's going with
lotus eaters people want to check out
what it is that you do where should they
go
uh they can search for the podcast of
the lotus seaters on youtube or just go
to lotus.com on the internet
sweet we made it man
thanks man what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace